there's a concern the railroad has a
serious concern which they can express
to you
about an explosion
with one or more of these cars
they describe an explosion as
potentially catastrophic
and could potentially explode causing
deadly disbursement of shrapnel and
toxic fumes
so following new modeling information to
conducted this morning by the Ohio
National Guard
Ohio Governor Mike dewine and
Pennsylvania Governor Josh Shapiro are
ordering an immediate evacuation in a
one mile by two mile area surrounding
East Palestine which includes both Ohio
and Pennsylvania to alleviate the risk
of this shrapnel
north of southern railroad is planning a
controlled release of the vinyl chloride
at approximately 3 30 pm
the controlled release of the toxic
chemicals also has the potential to be
deadly if inhaled
those in the red area those in the red
area
are facing grave danger of death
if they are still in that area
look let me just close uh by again
urging
everyone in Pennsylvania and Ohio who's
in this area
you know
you need to leave you just need to leave
we're ordering you to leave this is a
matter of life and death and what's
different now is we know that something
is going to happen around 3 30. this
controlled release will actually take
place and you are in imminent danger
you're in need to leave immediately